this is the moment a lithium battery
explodes engulfing a kitchen in an
Inferno part of a growing number of
fires linked to faulty batteries and
electric bikes and scooters
Dell Williams saw that Danger first hand
he bought a used e-scooter online watch
how it burst into flames at his home to
sound like explosion just happened like
all like you know and that when I've
gone towards I'm opening my door I've
seen orange flames on inside from the
other side of the door it's
undescribable woman it's like it's like
when you've been put in that situation
it's it's like
I'm lucky to be alive
not everyone escapes these incidents
unscathed a flat fire this weekend in
Cambridge is believed to have been
sparked by an e-bike left on charge
killing Gemma Germany along with her
children Lily and Oliver
as battery-powered bikes and scooters
become more popular Fire Chiefs are
warning the public to take extra care we
are seeing an increase in in these types
of fires and we kind of connect that
with the fact that people own more of
these types of light electric vehicles
people really need to be aware about
this type of incident given the fact
that they can be so ferocious and we've
seen the devastation that this can cause
and the tragedy that comes along with it
this electric bike manufacturer says
because e-bikes are costly with no
government subsidies available people
often revert to cheaper models and
batteries I charge my bag in the house
so I want to make sure that they're safe
you know let alone anybody else to sell
the bike to this battery has been tested
and certified one issue is there's an
influx in cheap batteries being bought
online some from places where
regulations aren't as strict
when batteries overheat consequences can
be catastrophic which is why some
experts are calling for tighter import
controls when a Lithium-Ion battery is
abused for example buying all by being
overcharged overheated crushed
or due to defects or contamination
introduced at the manufacturing stage
they generate huge amounts of gas and
huge amounts of heat with dangers now
being linked to increasingly popular
modes of Transport it's clear more
safety measures and scrutiny are needed
to avoid potentially deadly
circumstances so give my replay Sky News
Elites